todo parece entonces apuntar a que Rusia
no estaría detrás de este incidente le
parece más una posible hipótesis eh eh
lo que está un error de la defensa
ucraneal a lo que está manejando Rusia y
Estados Unidos en este momento
por el momento lo que es esenciales es
pegada a la conclusión de las de la
investigación que las autoridades
polacas están llevando a cabo en el
sitio del impacto
por el momento se dice que
puede ser hoy
el uso que fue lanzarote de algún modo
eventual territorio polaco o puede ser
la defensa anterior y ucraniana pero de
una persona u otra el resultado del
impacto es tiene el impacto tuvo como
origen el ataque que desató denuncia
sobre Ucrania el día de ayer entonces el
modo el origen de ese impacto se
mantiene en manos de Rusia claro también
hay reacciones encontradas Porque
mientras a China llama a la calma y
Estados Unidos responde de manera
mesurada Hay llamadas desde Ucrania para
que se invoque el artículo 5 de la otan
cuál Debería ser el paso a seguir tras
investigaciones
lo más probable es que vamos a ver un
llamado de la falta de Polonia del
artículo 4
de la Constitución de la otan para que
haya consultaciones entre los miembros
de la alianza para saber cómo responder
un llamado el artículo 5 en el que se
discutía una reacción colectiva a
proteger la defensa de los países
miembros de la otan no pagues estar en
las en la mesa por el momento más bien
se habla del artículo 4 pero todo esto
se mantiene un poco en el aire mientras
la investigación no ha concluido
evidentemente ante todo esto existen las
preocupaciones no de la comunidad
internacional y de las personas le
pregunto si hay riesgo de una escalada
del conflicto Si siguen presentándose
hechos o como estos
definitivamente mientras mientras
continúa mientras usa continuación de
Ucrania
los riesgos de una escalada sea de
manera vertical tal tal llamada en la
escala hacia la amenaza de usar además
nucleares Rusia ha estado haciendo Ya
varios meses
o una escaladora horizontal en el
conflicto se despaganda Por decirlo de
una manera hacia la zona hacia la
regiones colindantes en este caso afectó
a Polonia Pero podemos esperar que Tan
tanto se prolonga la guerra tanto
aumenta el riesgo que otros incidentes
semejantes se presenten en el futuro
Iván y y está la posibilidad real de que
esto ocurra digamos incidente ese como
esto o todo se podría calmar si Se
confirma entonces que este misil salió
de Ucrania digamos un error de cálculo
de la ucraniana como lo podrían estar
manejando y no de Rusia
Perdón no quisieran
no hay disposición para una escalada
entre estas dos partes por el momento
sobre todo no puedes ser incidente no
obstante creo que
lo que podemos esperar es que es
incidente va a forzar la unidad de la
alianza en su apoyo Ucrania pues se
constata de una vez más que la guerra se
continúa se amplifica estos riesgos que
al final afectan directamente a la
alianza